foreign
let's go out to uh Utah and talk to
brother Ryan what's up Ryan
hello Don how are you doing today I'm
doing great man how about you
I'm doing really well excellent
excellent what's up
well today I came to what did you hear
the question I'm wondering uh how do I
eliminate unhealthy emotionally charged
behaviors in my relationships with my
family and significant others when I'm
hurt and frustrated oh man how old are
you
uh I'm 21. 21.
what's emotional charge what does that
look like in real life
well I want to give you a little bit of
background on this okay so
uh when I was eight years old my parents
ended up splitting up that means
my memories of them are from about five
to eight years old of them being
together
and these memories include them fighting
name calling ghost being screaming and
yelling at each other and that's you
know what I learned to be normal
and um basically I noticed I have the
same tendency with my family today and
even my girlfriend
and I just you know they these these
were my normal
relationship uh situations and so how do
I fix that
oh man
how how much honesty can you handle
today
uh I think I can handle a lot a little
bit or a lot are you are you if if I lay
it on pretty good will we still be
friends
I'm open to it yes okay
um you mentioned the word tendency a lot
I want to throw that word out and never
use it again okay your parents
um beat each other up physically and
metaphorically I mean in in
psychologically and emotionally okay
that happened you saw all of that
and you also even at a young age knew
that's not right it scared you
it's all the only picture you had but
you knew it wasn't right
and so I want to fast forward to your 21
year old you're an adult
and screaming and yelling and carrying
on and being over emotional with someone
that you care about with anybody much
less your girlfriend
I want to take Mom and Dad out now
okay I don't want to continue to call
back to well this is just I know it's
just a tendency I have no you're
screaming and yelling and being abusive
to your girlfriend stop
is that fair
I think so yes
okay I know so tell me why you're
struggling because you know this hurts
her you don't feel good after you're
done screaming and hollering and acting
the fool why do you continue to do it
what does it get you
uh you know it doesn't get me anywhere
and it hurts me too but in the moment it
just feels so natural I guess it gets
you something what is it
although you wouldn't keep doing it
um
I guess that puts me in a position of
power over her sometimes okay
and that keeps you from feeling small
and little and scared like that
five-year-old little boy was when Mom
and Dad were screaming and smashing
things
does your girlfriend deserve to be
treated like this
no she doesn't anybody wanna change it
nobody goes okay
your parents cannot change your
situation in the present so let's stop
talking about them we know we've done
the tracing we know where it's from and
now he's got to come to the present how
um
how in are you on making a change here
I'm in
it's hard
because power is a a really really
um seductive mistress
like if you told me you wanted to quit
lying or quit uh cheating or quit like
man that's easier than
turning off the addiction to this
temporary feeling of power and strength
yes for sure
so here's what we're gonna do we're
going to create a new identity starting
right this second okay
from this point forward Ryan is a guy
who never yells
Ryan is a guy who never screams who's
never emotionally abusive that's not the
kind of guy you are that's not who you
are those are things that you never do
say it
I will never do those things
you're talking now see you skipped a
step you went straight to actions I
don't want I want identity
I'm a guy who fill in the blank use your
own words not mine
I'm a guy who loves people and treats
them well nope because I you can love
people and treat them well and also lose
your mind and throw temper tantrum and
screaming you
who are you
who are you gonna be from this point
forward
I guess someone who no no no guessing
say it Carl ramrod say it
I'm a guy who's gonna take care to make
sure I'm mindful of people's emotions
and take care of my own self oh my gosh
could you say it anymore like me Ryan
I'm a guy who does not scream at anybody
ever
ever I'm a guy who doesn't ever raise
his voice because I'm not a child
I'm a man who will not screamed because
I'm not a child anymore okay
I'm a man who will love my
girlfriend my future wife I love my kids
with a deep respect
I'm never going to take that from them
by trying to be overly powerful you
don't have to say all that but you get
what I'm saying this is going to take an
entire identity change because if you
just try to change actions what you're
going to do is what most dads do
most husbands do most boyfriends do and
you're just gonna Channel it somewhere
else
what do I mean by that
instead of screaming and yelling and
being all angry
you're gonna just
bury it deep inside your chest like a
nuclear reactor and everyone in the
house is going to know you're in a bad
mood but you're not gonna say anything
and then if she says are you okay what's
wrong you're going to get all mad why
are you always bothering me about me
being in a bad mood I'm fine you're the
one that keeps nagging me see what I'm
saying it's the same exact thing one is
just done with silence and one is done
with volume
so we're not going to focus so much
right this second on just doing a couple
of things differently we're going to
change Who We Are
and that starts with a proclamation I
will never yell at a person again if
that means in the middle of a fight or a
middle of a disagreement or I feel it
welling up inside of me I'm gonna look
at her and say I need five minutes and
you just Sprint out the front door and
go for a walk
that's what you're gonna do
that means you drop and do 20 push-ups
if that means you take a knee and you
say will you hold my hand that means if
you say no more talking I need I need we
need to finish this tomorrow
because I'm a guy who never yells
so like one of my core I'm a guy who
doesn't borrow money I just don't borrow
money
and so hey we need this thing well we're
not going to get this thing we have to
figure out another way to do it I'm
gonna have to go sell something I'm
gonna have fill in the blank I'm gonna
take on another job I'm gonna have to
take another shift I might take another
speaking gig because I'm a guy who
doesn't borrow money so that means I've
got to figure out another Avenue I've
taken it completely off the table
so that's the level of of identity shift
okay so that's number one number two you
have to decide I'm going to catch myself
when the feelings begin and I'm going to
take myself out of that situation I'm
gonna ask myself
what is my body trying to protect me
from I can almost guarantee you your
body is trying to protect you from
feeling powerless ever again because you
felt it when you were a kid and you
never want to feel it again am I right
or wrong
you're correct yeah
part of being in a relationship is
sometimes being
um the feeling small it's part of it
and the way to rebalance the power or
the the not the power the way to
rebalance your relationship is not
ripping somebody else down by their hair
and bringing them down below you that's
not it sometimes it's just standing up
you get that
so give me give me play it out for me
play out the scenario
um what what's the last when's the last
time you yelled and screamed and found
yourself just in a rage what happened
I don't know like something happened
recently that's what you're calling
right
it's been a little it's been a little
while but um yeah I guess I guess a
situation that I have is like
um
I was uh we're gonna clean up her car
right and um
she had another option from one of her
friends who was going to go to help her
but she wasn't like figuring it out and
I kind of just lost it I raised my voice
I didn't yell or anything I raised my
voice for sure about cleaning the car
yeah I know so stupid what about it what
about that moment made you raise your
voice what were you trying to
communicate
I guess I was trying to say that I'm
trying to
you know do something for her
um and when she has another option but
is not exploring it or trying to help me
with that
I was like I feel like I don't know what
to do and that was my first response was
to raise my voice and get frustrated
there
I don't think your first response is to
raise your voice to get frustrated with
her I think your first response is to
raise your voice so that you can get
those that your mom and your dad to look
at you
well somebody please look at me because
I'm scared I'm hurting
and Mom and Dad chose other options
and so when your girlfriend has another
option your body's just goes to Terror
mode and you have to learn to be an
adult and say
we were scared when we were five but now
we're 21.
now I'm 22 now I'm 30. now I'm 40. I
don't kick and scream like a child
anymore I acknowledge whoa whenever she
has another option it makes me feel
uncomfortable it makes me feel less than
man
the elsers
I need to choose enough to to work on
that to not feel like that I need to
reach back out and say hey you have a
million options I'd love to help you
with your car if you don't want my help
that's great I'm gonna go do something
else
that's you choosing peace not choosing
War
you get the difference
yes sir
do you want that
of course I want that I've got somebody
that just love chaos they just love it
man like they're content to die like
just in chaos and I don't understand it
I'm I'm just always wanting more and
more peaceful life
um
here's the thing that's worked for me
when I feel my body taken off on me I
literally will take my open hand and put
it on my chest
I'll take a deep breath and I will ask
myself what is my body trying to protect
me from
it is almost never it's almost never my
wife it's almost never my kids
it's almost always a feeling of I'm
feeling powerless I'm feeling less than
I'm feeling not important
and that's my issue not theirs
that's my issue not theirs
sounds like you spent a long time a lot
of years
blaming your late teen and early
adulthood behaviors and actions and
choices on your parents let's don't do
that anymore
as Jocko says let's take full ownership
let's take extreme ownership I'm Ryan
I'm 21 years old I'm an adult I'm old
enough to buy beer
from this point forward I'm a guy who
treats people with dignity and respect
never raises his voice because only
children raise their voice unless
they're trying to keep somebody from
falling off a bridge or getting hit by a
car or something
I don't raise my voice it's not who I am
it's not how I solve problems
and I'm a guy that when my body starts
to think off on me I feel it and I own
it and by the way this is just me being
vulnerable and honest
on Sunday
man I was grumpy I wasn't feeling I was
just feeling low just like a bum
um
it takes a second my son and I
um I my daughter got a trampoline for
Christmas and it's been sitting in the
garage I haven't had time to fix it and
my son has been asking me can we get
that up go get that up and I wanted to I
wanted a break
my son comes be-bopping and Dad can we
put up the trampoline today and I was
like you know what fine let's just do it
now he's like and he said whoa it's okay
Dad we have to do it today he knew it he
could feel it on me I was like no you
keep asking let's just get this done
we went outside and I was grumpy we got
it done I never raised my voice I never
yelled never got mad but I was I was a
nuclear reactor
and then yesterday was Monday
my son got home from school and he was
walking through like Hey Dad and I just
said hold on come here come here come
here
he said what happened and he kind of
froze like he was in trouble and I said
hey you are not in trouble and I grabbed
both sides of his face with my hands and
I held his face and I said yesterday I
was really just in a mood had nothing to
do with you that was about me
one of my favorite things about you is
you kept kept asking hey Dad can we do
something together can we do something
together can we do something together
can we build this thing because I know
our family is going to love having
trampoline back out there
can we do this thing together thank you
for not giving up on me son
my grumpiness was about me not you I'm I
was so fun getting to put that together
with you and he said thanks Dad and he
went to the Next Room
I said I was sorry you're gonna have to
say you're sorry a lot Ryan because
you're practicing a whole new way of
life let me tell you every second of it
is worth it put the effort in
when you're 23 24 you're not gonna be
this guy anymore because you're gonna
have practice you can have worked on it
you're gonna have grind scraped your
knuckles up here but you're gonna be a
guy who doesn't yell and scream you're
gonna be a guy who owns his feelings
treats people with dignity and respect
and is the person you're gonna be the
person who changes the family curse
forever
it's not gonna be fun but it's gonna be
worth it